es wimmelt unter unseren füßen insekten
die artenreichste klasse der tiere
seltsam fremd sind sie uns weniger von
intelligenz als von instinkt geleitet
wir schauen auf sie hinab
essen sie aber nicht
wie regeln uns zelebrieren insekten
essen als mutprobe für c promis im
dschungelcamp
doch angesichts wachsender
weltbevölkerung wassermangels und knappe
agrarfläche werden auch wir uns neue
protein quellen erschließen müssen in
der schweiz wirbt eine kleine lobby für
essbares auf sechs beinen jetzt ist ein
gesetz in der vernehmlassung ab 2016
regelt es welche insekten bei uns wie
auf den teller kommen noch nicht in
aller munde aber jetzt schon in allen
blättern in frankreich haben sie schon
den himmel eines sternekochs wie david
vor erreicht und in deutschland gibt es
bereits eine ganze restaurant kette
bongos allerdings führen sie auch hier
ein heimliches da sein
man findet sie auf der karte nur unter
kleinigkeiten
guido ritter ist professor in münster
und ein vordenker in sachen ernährung
feinschmecker und probier freudig von
berufs wegen
es gibt noch von anderen gründen
bei der zucht brauche weniger wasser als
bei anderen tierarten weniger platz um
insekten zu züchten insekten haben eine
sehr hohe transformations- raten wir
kriegen also viel tierisches eiweiß aus
pflanzlichem eiweiß heraus die insekten
werden in gesonderten pfannen hinten in
der küche zubereitet wonach schmeckt
dass er noch junge leicht
was ist eigentlich geschmack der
geschmack ist im prinzip ganz viel also
zum einmal nehmen wir bei uns zunge süß
sauer salzig bitter und den oman
geschmack den geschmack nach protein
eiweiß war
wir nehmen aber auch mit dem gesamt
geschmack auch aromen war und wir
verarbeiten dass in unserem gehirn und
haben da sozusagen die stufe ruhe sagen
dass eignet sich für die ernährung oder
nein das lass ich besser weg alles
andere was wir an ihm haben ist rein
soziokulturell erworben und kulturell
bedingt viele kulturkreise in asien und
afrika in süd und mittelamerika kennen
diese tabus nicht als ähnlich dieser
käfer suppe aus laos kannte man in
frankreich die susanne thon in
deutschland und in der schweiz die
maikäfer suppe dann wurden wir immer
reicher und zeigten dass in dem wir
fleisch aßen jetzt müssen insekten die
speisekarte erst langsam zurück erobern
also auftreten kann ist das hier
insekten achtmal so essen dass wir sie
nicht vollständig sehen also das was wir
heute hier essen ist eine sehr schöne
mischung wir haben also die heuschrecken
und wagen den wir haben es aber auch zum
teil eingebacken tempura wo wir gar
nicht mehr auf den ersten blick erkennen
dass insekten sind weil keine
beinschienen viele rausgekommen deshalb
ist das hier eine sehr schöne
kombination und so wird auch insekten
hat man bei uns einzug halten
andere denken schon einen schritt weiter
französische snacks der zukunft die so
zukünftig gar nicht sind denn alles was
drin ist hat anderswo bereits gegessen
in einem experiment kann guido ritter
zeigen dass nur der geschmack angeboren
ist nicht aber der ekel vorausgesetzt
die versuchsperson weiß nicht was sie im
sensoriklabor ist neben grillen
heuschrecken und mehlwürmer moerser
kilometer auch brot und cashewkerne zu
gleichgroßen krümeln
ist es zynisch oder pflanzlich ich würde
auf die cashewkerne hätten die sind ja
so ähnlich tatsächlich grillen
hier liegen sie also falsch wenn der
geschmack fast gleich ist dann liegt es
an unserer kultur dass wir lieber
cashewkerne als grillen essen.de regel
ist eigentlich unbegründet weil er nur
im kopf als fantasie sozusagen abläuft
in der form ohne dass man es weiß würden
viele leute das tatsächlich nicht
erkennen
man muss es einfach nur mal probieren
genau so hätten insekten gute chancen
das sushi des nächsten jahrzehnts zu
werden